cette fois ils ont décidé de se faire
entendre
cet après-midi beaucoup de jeunes sont
venus grossir les rendus cortège
parisien au total
93000 personnes ont défilé selon la
préfecture de police
parmi ces jeunes certains sont là pour
la première fois comme Dina de Fresnes
motivé par le déclenchement du 49-3 à
Lille lui aussi est bien déterminé à se
battre jusqu'au bout depuis plusieurs
semaines Mathis 21 ans enchaîne les
manifestations et rassemblements quand
on parle de la jeunesse et quand elle
est dans la rue on parle du dentifrice
le dentifrice une fois qu'il est sorti
du tube on n'arrive pas à le faire
rentrer la jeunesse restera sur le
terrain tant que on n'aura pas de
changement selon le syndicat étudiant UF
pas moins de 400 000 jeunes ont défilé
aujourd'hui en France donc 70000 à Paris
c'est près de 4 fois plus que lors de la
dernière journée de mobilisation là
d'avoir de la menthe sucrée dans la
douche le dentifrice j'avais envie de la
vallée j'avais vraiment envie de le
manger
j'ai mangé un peu de dentifrice
c'est chaud mais je l'ai fait les jeunes
c'est comme le dentifrice
c'est plus facile à faire sortir qu'à
faire rentrer et puis il y a celui qui
est repartirait pas avec les 100000
balles N'oubliez pas les paroles
Sarkozy
qui avait utilisé la fameuse phrase en
disant quand il quand les jeunes sont
sortis du dentifrice du type de
dentifrice on peut plus rêver
plus de 80 université bloquée
aujourd'hui et surtout on a 450 lycées
bloqué en France dont 60 en
Île-de-France et donc c'est une
mobilisation qui est en train de prendre
de plus en plus d'ampleur
partout en France avec 740 000
manifestants selon le ministère de
l'intérieur ou plus de 2 millions selon
les syndicats les cortèges étaient moins
fournis que la semaine dernière que ce
soit à Rennes Bordeaux ou encore
Saint-Étienne
la plupart des manifestants se disent
pourtant encore déterminer pour eux il
n'y a qu'une seule issue à ce mouvement
social
c'est le retrait et après après on
discute le slogan star de cette
contestation c'est celui-ci vu dans
toute la France ma pancarte est toute
pourrie ma retraite le sera aussi ma
pancarte est toute pourrie ma retraite
le sera aussi ma pancarte est toute
pourrie ma retraite le sera aussi et
alors que le pays est hors du tendu que
faisait le Président hier bah il
s'adonnait à sa plus grande passion
réalisé des shootings mystérieux aériens
et pensifs
je suis beau la grogne je suppose
l'embrasement je suis
beau que dire que faire je ne le sais
49 toi la nouvelle Eau de Parfum
d'Emmanuel Macron les Britanniques
s'inspirent de nous avec le hashtag
Beamer French soyons plus français tout
est parti de cet article paru dans le
télégraphe le journaliste y invite ses
concitoyens à se mobiliser comme en
France contre leur gouvernement et leur
futur réforme des retraites
très utilisé sur les réseaux sociaux
[Applaudissements]
outre-Manche des internautes vont même
jusqu'à faire l'éloge du flegme français
en partageant des vidéos de manifestants
dansant sous les canons à eau ou en
terrasse à quelques mètres d'un feu
c'est à dire le français qui boit
l'apéritif avec un et puis voilà l'air
de rien comme si rien était en train de
se passer alors certains disaient que ça
c'est pas pendant le moment ici nos amis
de vérificateurs TF1 info ont vérifié
c'est bien jeudi dernier place de la
Victoire à Bordeaux le secteur du
tourisme lui aussi impacté aujourd'hui
la Tour Eiffel l'Arc de Triomphe et le
château de Versailles sont restés fermés
du côté de Clermont-Ferrand c'est une
manifestation symbolique pour Philippe
Martinez sa dernière en tant que
secrétaire général de la CGT quand on
écoute les salariés parler de leur
boulot on comprend tout de suite que
deux ans de plus c'est pas possible
voilà c'est ça la réalité certains
prélèvent ainsi une partie des
cotisations de leurs adhérents pour
aborder un fond qui est utilisé dans ce
type de circonstances et la plus
importante de ces caisses c'est la
Caisse nationale d'action syndicale
créée en 1973 par la CFDT un demi siècle
après sa création elle dispose ainsi
d'un trésor de guerre de 14
un million d'euros qui sert non qui sert
à financer les jours de grève de ses
adhérents
5500 policiers et gendarmes déployés 10
000 contrôles réalisés on était
quasiment à tous les événements et je
crois que la première fois qu'on fouillé
à l'entrée oui pourquoi pas après
rassurer pas forcément Mélenchon sur les
plateaux de télévision on fait votre
procès matin midi et soir il y a pas un
homme politique à droite qui dit on
défend la police il faut que ce soit
modestement moi qui viennent dire ce
matin mais mais dans quel pays vit-on
huit jours huit jours madame Ernotte
présidente France Télévisions a dit
quelque chose elle dit quelque chose
pour défendre la police enfin où on est
si jamais on est directement gazé par du
gaz lacrymogène on peut avoir évidemment
plein de symptômes puisque ça va tout
simplement provoquer des brûlures avec
de l'irritation au niveau des yeux on
comprend assez facilement une production
de mucus et de l'arbre on a les yeux qui
coulent le nez qui coule on va se mettre
à tousser on va voir des vomissements et
parfois on peut avoir aussi des signes
de brûlure cutanées au niveau de la peau
mais aussi au niveau des yeux j'ai rien
contre France Télévisions moi j'essaye
simplement de décrypter toujours et
parce que c'est pas rien quand même le
service public j'essaye je vous assure
j'ai rien contre France
Inter ce que si vous aviez quelque chose
contre eux
je vous assure
je vous assure j'ai rien d'abord j'ai
rien contre personne en général j'essaye
simplement de ne pas être dupe non mais
j'ai rien vous les attaquer quasiment
tous les jours quelques conseils de bon
sens si jamais ça vous arrive et que par
malheur vous êtes aspergé de mauvaise
lacrymogène utilisez si vous en avez une
lingette sans alcool ou un mouchoir à
usage unique en évitant de se frotter
les yeux avec sa manche manche qui va
être contaminée par du gaz lacrymogène
rincez les yeux avec un sérum adapté
pour les yeux ou alors avec de l'eau et
si jamais les symptômes persistent de
brûlure oculaire au-delà d'une heure ou
deux je vous recommande d'aller voir un
ophtalmo
pardon je m'étouffe c'est la fin de ce
journal réalisé pardon dans des
conditions particulières en raison de la
grève d'une partie du personnel